I came here for karate about that that
baby with the fish that's looking I
don't think you should hold a baby like
that guy on the right with a beard and
the beanie
I don't know that is that guy in the
raincoat the guy from the you know that
the frozen fish stick box that you oh oh
okay oh it's everybody who made it and
do they each have kids I I look at me
like that
okay all right they're all dead now
fathers of this scene oh I get it
hi hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to draymond Green
draymond greens shut up and slow okay
alright then in a rec center somewhere
in America hello mr. green I'm afraid
there's been a mix-up we've accidentally
double-booked your charity basketball
then oh no my friends Chris Paul Metta
World Peace and others have taken time
out of their schedules for the children
success hundreds of people have already
shown up for a crazy another job miss
lady moving we have a prom natural y'all
should know how much I love karate what
you're gonna dunk and kick me in the
junk to jump ok I'm not try not to lose
my mind about this but this might either
be the most amazing experience of my
life or the most horrifying so I don't I
don't know I don't I don't know I'm
gonna be on the King come little stop to
put your party drop I'm gonna go for
this because I'm high III got no I got
okay alright it's just me now we're just
about ready for the tip I'd be told
we're about to witness the first
historic in carnage I have no idea how
to play okay oh okay how do I grab the
goddamn ball ow excuse you sir this is
not civil can I
I wasn't ready all right can I just how
do I grab
okay no it's okay ha ha ha okay give it
to me give me give me the ball give me
the ball give me the ball give me the
ball
oh okay okay ah yeah okay I think I'm
playing basketball I'm learning out a
slam pipe lately okay how he's my dad
okay all right then it's working out
monstro we are now destroying them don't
get up don't even think about getting up
that's right don't get up go oh oh oh oh
range good night ha ha ha ha okay I got
huh oh that's not what I meant to do
well okay all right I'm getting it I'm
getting in it in it like a lot don't get
holy crap weird oh my goodness oh my
goodness oh I gotta bunk lines that is a
slam jam Wow three point fill me - stop
it
just show me the zappity to the press
booth oh hey hang on I'm just jumping
freely there we go holy crap is God boy
man
oh wait yes Paul you have a cup do you
have a cop this is hot I'm going for it
hey well it's a little uncalled for and
get your man's job as a man jam or a
woman's Jam I don't was he thinking
gripping stuff yeah a couple of players
still gripping their nuts don't want to
ice those as soon as they get off the
court what are you talking about
rambling over the movie ball Oh Jay hang
on listen man listen hang on hang on a
gosh darn second yeah holy [ __ ]
all right you guys gonna be you guys
need to stop for a gosh-darn second here
because I need to collect my tool I am
literally only kicking them in the mouth
that's all I'm doing these guys harder
than they were before because we would
be a little harder to be able to get all
away from them I'm gonna go for the free
whoopsie
I used to play over I used to I used to
play NBA Slam Jam all the time I was
doing those American Nick I'll kick you
in the Ned all right okay Kimmy can we
just talk about this simile boys their
beach ball on the kings of parking right
all right guys maybe your here is my
teammate dunk gonna get this ball throw
this ball go okay are you throwing it to
loser loser loser t hat to bebop me man
I'm gonna line this up like that
no so again it's just that a broken
bottle doesn't even a karate tournament
anymore I don't know what bro look clean
for my ulcer Wow
okay all right you guys need to calm
down here a little bit because I have no
idea all the kids are very happy about
this but I'm still trying to reel my
head around and I don't even have them
and basketball all right hang on wait
just hold on coming to class we caused
it room how do we stop it the odds it
magnums always lose for charity
listen to me please I am NOT trying that
how do I stop this crazy machine how do
we stop there we go I don't know what's
going on here
I barely know basketball of this that's
Katherine specialty but as far as I know
kicking people in the junk even if it
rhymes isn't the right thing to do in
these situations we need to talk simply
about this because for charity we need
to remember that it's for the kid unless
in our next charity livestream you wants
to play basketball and then repeatedly
kick each other in the ditch
cuz that's an option I'm not going to
throw it out there I'll set it with the
team but maybe they're on board with it
so I bet Tyler would be okay with that
anyway I'm gonna try it on hard this
time Tiago I'm ready
bring it on tonight how much worse could
it be I gotta remember to roll to do
them oh that's right whoa hey hey hey
miss menos met me jumped it now dorchen
don't kick there we go thank you for
that I'm gonna go for three
well thousand myths I'll say there
aren't even anybody playing from the
karate tournament so I would probably
only be worried by the cooler on the
floor okay all right ah ha ha two points
Bolton the reps are against me going
tonight sprint please don't let him down
car don't undo plan hey Monica win me to
shoot that minute take that juice is
apparently just basketball guys is what
it always good to be a junk come over
here savages oh hey everybody else is
just dad on the field that's what I call
the basketball field ride the field what
it is nice
they're not gonna hold my breath man I
wish this had like like mobile online
multiply out get him guy damn damn it
come on oh come one holy crap there's
definitely going to be a lot of
strategies if like I actually think
conceptually there's a really cool game
Oh miss me pull this be now comes the
Slam Jam sorry thank you swam yeah Thank
You Man thank you thank you guys exactly
what I was going for the slam damn thang
man behind the arc
the crowd is elated after witnessing a
stunning display of karate and
basketball you can hear them cheering
they're so happy about it they're fun
and friend doing great with their lives
I'm gonna do that again okay all right
you didn't really need me to help out
there because you seem to have honor
control i da good yeah I didn't know
karate involved so much dick kickin pass
it to me pass me the spike pass me the
Lube have me the moil oh yeah oh they're
kicking my boy somehow we're cooking
this why BAM why'd you shoot it then why
shoot it you why'd you shoot it to me
then buddy laughing ah yeah oh come on
get kick can the dad give it to me
cheese um why did I drop that guy that
goes down by putting a car
why why are you going that way buddy
what you doing with my teammates doing
come on give it give it give it just go
whoa
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah I want to do
something here can you let me have some
fun
Oh God again how am I always down oh
okay
all right then it was a lot more fun
when I was just wiping the floor with
you guys can you not do that holy give
it to me now now would be the right time
give it today thank you
Oh slam damn why I'll come on in midair
oh don't do that
who you passing it to your teammates on
the ground card oh boy can I get back up
there
quit ah okay miss me cool thank you for
finally slam jamming while you're on
your own
dad and then the bridge
oh we've picked up the lead again oh
yeah Wow does the game-winning
three-pointer reporter slam jam he put
in work kickin Steve Adams in the nuts
all those times in the 2016 conference
finals and it really paid off tonight I
mean okay I mean I get what you're
saying now but anyway your dad is really
fun that exactly was it really fun I
wish I could play with other people
because didn't it was really fun I mean
I'm not saying it's fun to kick people
in the nuts don't do that but playing
basketball at the same time totally
legitimate do that all day long
I shouldn't encourage this job just fix
junk that's a good life lesson to learn
how this Michael Jordan in that
basketball ad he should have remembered
that when he was talking about don't
doing drugs also come on don't do it
it's not worth it
protect your junk eat a mac donnell get
a six piece of chicken McNuggets come on
Nick burgers it's chicken get your Big
Mac don't do drugs so if you want play
this for yourself you can play with
friends because apparently it's
four-player local multiplayer because
that's really fun and there's not a lot
of couch co-op games going on lately and
I remember when I was playing uh like
the NES the Super Nintendo version of
this like way back in the day let's jump
kick itch but a lot more Slamdance a lot
of fun so thank you everybody so much
for watching there's a link down the
description for you to play for yourself
and as always I
we'll see you in the next video bye
[Music]